hello my name is Dominic Butler and I'm
the lead game designer on Ghost Recon
wildlands in Ghost Recon wildlands we
are four players the total freedom of
choice as they fight to take down the
Santa Blanca cartel
a few months ago at e3 our four ghosts
raided a camp to extract el pozolero a
boots on of the Santa Blanca cartel
today we want to show you another way to
play the same mission taking a stealth
approach and using the cover of night to
our advantage
Wever nomads and holds our base-jumping
from the helicopter this is one of the
60 plus vehicles available in the game
for you to use as you explore the world
today for devs are playing the demo in
co-op but Ghost Recon wildlands is
entirely playable from beginning to end
in solo where you're supported by your
AI teammates Weaver has landed on a
cliff nearby to gain a vantage point and
provide cover for nomad and Holt who are
now landing and moving towards a cartel
checkpoint all four ghosts are now on
the ground midas will regroup with the
others in the camp
Ghost Recon wildlands features a
complete day and night cycle as well as
a realistic weather system which both
have an influence on gameplay here for
example nighttime with rainy weather is
a perfect combination for a stealthier
approach ideally we want to gain access
without alerting the cartel so it's time
to be creative
the ghosts know that this truck is being
used for local deliveries if they can
take it they can use it to get into the
camp without raising suspicion our
ghosts are getting into position now
tagging their enemies and identifying
their targets
[Music]
mr. stone
Midas is now using the slingshot feature
to assign targets to his teammates the
sync shot makes its comeback in
wildlands and is the perfect feature to
coordinate your action with your team
here we go and that's a perfect
execution
playing solo you'll be able to issue
simple orders to your AI teammates to
achieve this same deadly result now
nomads in hold are going to use the
truck to get into the camp without being
detected
the cartel recognized his truck and so
the ghost sorry
[Music]
holder's jumped out of the truck and is
preparing a possible exit strategy by
placing some c4 landmines frag flash and
diversion grenades will also give you
the explosive edge and help create
diapers with more than 50 weapons
available in the game that you are able
to use and customized with hundreds of
different attachments it's up to you to
choose the right weapon for the job each
of them has its own ballistics model
with piercing dispersion and bullet drop
[Music]
[Music]
Weaver's now deploying his drone to
further recon the area he switched the
thermal vision to easily detect local
targets other special upgrades can be
added to the drone - including an EMP
pulse that deactivates electronics and
noise generator or high explosives
okay that's our guy el pozolero
working late into the night
[Music]
now that we have his exact location no
Matt is going to park the truck near the
target in order to complete your mission
coordination and communication are key
[Music]
Nomad is now in position waiting for the
right moment to grab the target Midas is
heading towards the camp to rejoin hold
and Nomad
[Music]
Weaver has located the camp generator
with his drone if the team manages to
shut it down their kill power in the
camp which will prevent triggering
alarms or secondary reinforcements Midas
is now making his way into the camp
avoiding the patrols enroute to the
generator
[Music]
[Music]
whole displacing more c4 and the other
side of the camp to provide further
distraction in case the ghost needed
during their escape
the diversion grenade is another great
tool that can be used to distract
enemies since we're attacking this camp
at night we can take advantage of each
NPCs unique day and night agenda for
example this soldier here is taking a
rest
back to Midas is keeping a low profile
to avoid being detected
Holt is making his way towards no man in
el pozolero his location
[Music]
leave them in the game making sure you
don't leave bodies to be discovered is
key to preventing the camp going on full
alert you can grab and drag your enemies
away from the patrol pad so when you
knock them out they're out of sight
[Music]
Midas is climbing between the camp
buildings to reach a better position
all the while Weaver continues to
provide cover
having reached the generator Midas can
disable it to kill the lights throughout
the camp the o mat is activated as night
vision to get closer to a puzzler
now while enemies don't have night
vision they will become suspicious as to
why the lights are suddenly out now we
need to extract our target from the camp
the enemies are now alerted by the noise
and are trying to find its origin
jeez
Holt is passing a rebel prison cage the
rebels are another faction in the game
they have their own conflict with the
Santa Blanca so they'll spontaneously
engage whenever they get the chance
no matters just put our target into the
truck and is moving towards the exit
Weaver is liberating another group of
rebels this camp is now erupting into a
full gunfight between the rebels and the
satellite
and to provide further disruption we
blow that c4 we placed earlier
Weaver is now headed to rejoin the
others clearing the last of the Sante
Blanc in the wild who were attracted by
the gunshots
so now with the el pozolero in our
custody we're going to deliver them to
our rally point learn key information
about the cartel and his bosses
that's the end of the demo I hope you
enjoyed seeing our ghosts approaching
this mission in stealth just one of the
many ways you can play Ghost Recon
wildlands don't forget to check Ghost
Recon comm for the latest news and
updates on the game
[Music]
you
[Music]